hey everybody welcome to the first
edition of my new podcast just getting
started i am your humble host
rich eisen um and i'm thrilled to be
here uh on a new platform with westwood
one
and i'm thrilled to be here with a new
pod and
you know when it first came before me
placed before me about doing another
podcast doing something
new uh with my new partner of westwood
one
and the template was completely wide
open and i i
sat down and i thought to myself what do
i want it to be about
what i want to bring to the equation
and how can it be different than what i
do
every day what i'm fortunate to do every
day
on a show with my own name on it which
you can also get a podcast right here on
westwood one the podcast version of the
rich eisen show or
what i've done on nfl network or or espn
before that how can i do something
different
while also doing what i love to do which
is um
interviewing people and talking to
people and getting to know them and
having stories told that you
would like to hear and placing you and
my shoes which is what i've been doing
with
nfl network since it started in 2003
taking you
along with me in a journey through the
world of the nfl and
meeting players and coaches and talking
about the game that we all love and so
on and so forth
and i sat down and i decided let's do a
pod
um and when i said that i wasn't talking
to myself in the royal we i was talking
to the
folks at westwood one let's do a pod
about origin stories
about i'll interview people and get from
them
stories about how they started on their
journey because
i cannot
break away i cannot
turn away from what's going on
in the real world these days i cannot
turn a blind eye to the number of people
i hear about
i know about whose lives have been
turned upside down by this
awful pandemic and what is going on in
this world
outside of my sports world that i
usually live in
or the toy department which is what my
my graduate school professor at
journalism school
in northwestern called it i work in the
tour department i i talk about
wins and losses and real life does crash
in from time to time but i want to talk
real life stuff with real people who
happen to be
people that you may know because you
like their work or you watch their work
or you follow what they've done in their
world of business
you follow you know what they've done to
make themselves successful
and find out about their origin stories
because
so many of these folks that we
follow and watch and talk about and
either
follow on social media or enjoy their
work
on tv and music or read their books
or used to know in a certain role and
have come to
enjoy their new work
everybody started off somewhere and
everybody's had a door slamming in their
face
everybody's been told no everybody's had
some self-doubt
everybody and that includes me and
throughout this
show this pod not just today
but throughout the life of it and i hope
there's a nice long life of it
i'll share my stories about how i got
started
and the doubts that i had and the belief
in myself that i've always had
no matter how many times i've heard no
and no matter how many times i've had a
door literally slammed in my face
and hopefully if you are somewhere
listening to this taking in this pod
or watching it because we're gonna
record it uh each week and put it on
my show's youtube page and other places
um at rich eisenshow um on youtube.com
rich eisenshow um that
that you'll take something out of it
that you
if you are trying to figure out
what's next for you or you're in a spot
that you never thought you'd be because
of what the hell's happened in this
world
or if you are going through the pandemic
and you're getting through it and you've
decided once you are through it
or once you feel like you've come to the
water's edge
that you want to try something else but
you're too concerned about the risks or
you're wondering if it's the right thing
to do
and you have a family you've got a
mortgage you've got a lot going on or
you're trying to
build up enough to
get something in your life that you feel
that you need or
even better deserve that maybe there are
some stories here
that you can take as as you go along
and learn something also enjoy some of
the stories you hear
cause some you know we'll we'll stroll
into the world of pop culture with
certain guests
especially our first one who we'll get
to in a second
i just wanted to start this pod by just
talking about
why i decided to do a show called just
getting started
about origin stories about people going
down the journey
of going from point a to b and b is in
most cases
on the show going to be a very
successful point b
but point a is always all around the map
all over the globe
literally figuratively all over the map
and hopefully from this journey from a
to b
i'll pull out some stories that you can
take with you
and maybe use as inspiration
so that's what just getting started is
gonna be and my first guest
is a perfect first guest because not
only of how
successful he is and how entertaining
his stories are
but his journey is quite something and
he told it in his book
green lights and we'll talk about all
that with matthew mcconaughey
on the inaugural episode of just getting
[Music]
[Applause]
started
and pleased to have my first guest right
here on just getting started is one of
my favorite guests from my show that i
do every day with westwood one the rich
eisen show
uh he's the academy award-winning and
golden globe winning actor and also
author of this new york times bestseller
green lights
right here the author the man himself
matthew mcconaughey how are you matthew
good rich eisen good to see you man
always good sound talk to you
yeah good to see you as well what's
going on with you how's life in general
for you
otherwise relatively pretty good we're
down here in texas um
trying to unfreeze you know we lost
power when we lost power
water pipes froze then when they froze
water pipes busted so we got a lot of
a lot of water troubles down here texas
gonna need plumbers for some time
yeah but we're uh navigating throwing
together benefit we've got some real
good talent coming up we're gonna raise
some money to help out some people that
need it right now
that's fantastic knock on wood i want to
learn a little bit more about that but
you know you're you're again one of my
favorite guests and
people to talk to um when uh when i just
have a few minutes with you
and for me to start my new pod and it's
about
again uh just getting started i just
described to the audience essentially
that i want this pod to
give somebody something portable in this
day and age where obviously
so many lives have been turned upside
down and so many people are wondering if
the path that they're on is the path
they should take and
you're perfect for this man again your
book green lights as you said is a love
letter to life
and it's about turning red lights and
yellow lights into green lights
and just about origin stories and i i i
you're you're just a perfect person to
ask
uh the general sense about just getting
started and how
you got started what what doubts did you
have when you were first starting out
yourself matthew what doubt i had many
doubts uh the unknown geez oh man and
you said something really cool i haven't
heard put this way
you want to give something you want to
give people something portable yes
meaning what we take with us
when we're out of class what can we take
with us when we're outside of
our church or whatever that is when
we're not in our comfort zone that we
can have in our hip pocket in our souls
and go yep
i can use this approach in life and
it'll help me navigate
i think that's a good way to put it
portable um doubts for me
look man i have calibrated and
recalibrated thousands of times
i have had grand plans that i thought
were a lead pipe cinch there ain't no
way this can go wrong
and either i imploded or the world
exploded it for me and i sat there going
oh geez
um i've also had you know written many
headlines first
before i had any idea how i was going to
get there and live the story to them
and had successes that way i've also had
many times where i just
hardest part about me going into what i
was gonna do was just to tie my shoes
get out the damn door jump off the cliff
figure out how to fly on the way down
seems like that's sort of the art of of
life
making plans and then knowing that
change is going to come anyway
um the unknown and doubts of just
knowing the answer that's something that
i think
that we all have we want to know the
answer can you make it tangible can you
tell me what i'm going to get if i
take this risk can you tell me i want to
see my reward
so i can okay now that i see it clearly
now i can go for well rewards aren't
really like that
and usually even if we have an idea of
what they are when we're going into
something
they aren't what we thought they were
when we get there anyway so
i think the doubt is in what is it what
is an accomplishment going to be
what is uh uh um every there's even
unknowns when we're very secure about
where we're going
and that's not all the time so i mean
doubts
in saying you're gonna have more doubts
if you're only seeking a result
i guess is what i'm gonna say you have
less doubts if you're like hey
or you wanna have less doubts you'll
lean into the comfort of doubting of
going hey i'm not about the result i'm
going to enjoy the process of doing what
i need to do
and hell i'll look up one day and i'll
see where i am and if we do that over
and over
that's sort of leaning into the the the
doubt and embracing
yourself well i mean and again in the
folks who might
not have read your book because you do
cover this ground in your book
uh and just seeing you know you being
you um
having the trophies in the in the case
and also
you know a book that's a bestseller and
also you know you're
you're uh the ceo of austin fc a soccer
team
and they see all uh that's just some of
the trappings of success and that you
were always
meant to be an actor always thought you
were gonna be an actor to start
and that wasn't the case at all for you
no no it wasn't
and look you know i say earlier i
calibrated recalibrated many times i
thought i was gonna be a lawyer
um that's all i ever talked about in in
our household i was a good debater i
could make a good argument that's what
you're going to be a lawyer
and i think if i would have done that i
could have gone and been a somewhat
successful lawyer
but come my sophomore year in college
i'm not sleeping well with the idea of
being a lawyer the idea of going to
school four more years
after school and basically being able to
have my imprint in society when i'm in
my 30s did not appeal to me
i've been writing short stories i wanted
to get in the storytelling business but
now i got to call my dad and ask him
permission because he's paying for
school
scary proposition coming from the blue
collar family i come with an idea
of working into arts for a living i
thought was gonna be met with a lot of
what the hell are you talking about boy
and instead
he flipped the script on me and when i
told him i want to go to film school
instead of law school he said don't
half-ass it so he gave me not only his
approval he gave me a kick in the
backside
freedom accountability and
responsibility to do that um
even then i didn't know i mean i i bring
this up in the book and this is going to
somewhat answer i think your first
question as well
about what if i
what i was saying is that there's always
doubt but i will say this i say this in
the book sometimes it's not what
decision we make
let's just make one and commit to the
damn thing because
we all weigh should i do this or should
i do this is it her is it him
is it now is it and all of a sudden we
can look up next week and we're still
weighing them
and we look up next month and we're
doing it next year all of a sudden a
decade goes by and we're still in limbo
going well i don't know but
sometimes it's just like man pick one
that actually which decision you make
may not even be as important as jumping
into one and committing
and if you jump into a decision and
commit to it it quickly reveals whether
it was the right decision
or not or it reveals another option for
you that maybe you didn't even think
about
so i don't know i've been decent at
taking risks and rolling the dice
you know in my life and uh i don't like
that feeling that a lot of us are in
right now we're all in limbo right now
what's the future hold where am i going
we've all been disrupted so
sometimes though it is about just making
a choice committing to it and you'll
find out later
and then did you ever get a door slammed
in your face and if so how'd that happen
i had doors landed in my face i have
been told this this is a very good thing
my manager told me this
she was in a call one day and and and
this is the coolest way to get a door
slam in your face i've ever heard she
goes
um matthew
shut that door and get on the other side
of it
i was like can you say what a cool way
to tell somebody to get the hell out of
here shut that door and get on the other
side of it
um nice slammed
no but or a doubt or something like that
again like i i just wanna
because again uh it just seems to me it
for for for me when i was first just
getting started in my
in my career the number of times that i
was hoping to get a job
somewhere and the person in charge
um told me i didn't have it right or
told me i didn't have what it takes or
and i i had to sit there and i had to
truly just look within and just say you
know what i
still believe that what i believe i can
do
is something i can achieve and it does
sound something simple you know what i
mean but it does sound simple but
it is it happens to everybody it really
does
so i just figured i'd i mean i've been
told many many many many times
i know you know like you
i've gotten certain jobs or successes
by failing five times in a row and i got
the job because the person who succeeded
the first time was standing around going
well i'm done you're gonna pick me and
then all of a sudden whoever was doing
the hiring was like wait who's charlie
hustle down here who keeps failing
and he keeps getting up and doing it
again doing it again i like i want this
guy on my team
so i have gotten some jobs by failing
more often and
and consistently um
look i've i've had some bright ideas
that sure as hell didn't work
let me tell you a funny story about a
movie i got i was going through a time
in my career early on where i wasn't
getting a lot of jobs and because i was
too tight and i was too conservative and
i wasn't taking risk
and i was for the first time learning
about my craft of acting
well as we all know if you have the
instincts for something which i did
when you then go to learn about it
there's a there's an awkward time there
where you're intellectualizing what you
actually have the instincts to do and
that's the time i was in
so i get this job this blind offer on
this job no audition needed come on in
you're you're playing this role this
this drug lord on the on the southern
border
in texas and mexico and the coyotes will
come by you don't pay for your drugs you
shoot them all kill them and take it
it's that bad guy roll right
so i tell myself it's my bright idea
i've been really tight
in my auditions lately i'm going to go
back to how i was when i first started
acting
when i had no script when i didn't know
what i was doing where i would just
improvise that was wooderson and daisy
confused
i just knew my man and didn't said what
i would do so i get this idea on this
script of this
this job i said i'm not going to read
the script i'm not going to read the
scene
i'm not going to read any of that i'm
just going to know my man and go do what
i would do
yeah right idea so i show up i don't i
haven't read the script i'm on set i'm
on the mark we're about to shoot the
scene all of a sudden a
um pa comes by goes mr mcconnell would
you like to see the sides
to read the sides of the scene i said
sure obviously i started feeling a
little insecure about my plan because
now
i look at it and i got a page one
page two page three
page four four page monologue
by my guy in the scene oh my god
in spanish
now i get i get this bead of sweat comes
up on the back of my head going oh
no and i remember saying to no one in
particular
i just yelled that hey can i get 12
minutes here
my thinking was 12 minutes is not too
long to inconvenience the crew but maybe
long enough to learn a four-page
monologue in spanish because hey i took
semester of spanish in the 11th grade
well it was not enough time to learn it
i came back 12 months later did the
scene never been able to watch it too
embarrassed
uh i don't know what i did but on the
way home from work that day
i pulled over and and just started
bawling on the side of the road oh so
damn embarrassed
about this bright idea and my total
lackluster
idea to go i'm not gonna prepare and
from that day on
i learned about preparation from that
day on i said okay so that was a door
slam in my face that i slammed the door
in my own face sure
right by a bride i did from that day on
i said man i will out prepare
people now what comes next right after
that i get offered a roll like the
number eight
role in a time to kill smaller role
weeks work
i meet with the director well before i
meet with this director joel schumacher
about time to kill
i'm not only reading the scenes the
script for my character i'm reading the
book
and after reading the book i'm like well
who's this guy jake began
the lead cat that's the guy i want to be
so i go
to that meeting with him about this
other smaller role
and i have the gall to say i think i
should play jake perkins
he laughs no way that's ever going to
happen
well it ended up working out because i
was so damn prepared
coming into that meeting that i was able
to plant the seed and tell him why i
should be baking jake began
which ended up happening and
i saw the film you didn't speak a lick
of spanish in that film
uh i haven't seen it you saw it
have i told you that story before no no
no
no not at all no no i i just but i i was
just remarking again that
something born out of experience
you that's portable right that's
something that you took
that you remove that you you carry with
you yeah
and then you unpack it yeah and success
is born out of it
right not only hey i know what i want to
do to succeed
born out of initially hey i know i don't
even want to feel that way again
hey that embarrassment that oh man that
that was heavy
so sometimes we talk about this we don't
know what we want to do
or exactly who we are but damn it we
have a lot more clear about who we what
we don't want to do
what we don't want to feel again so by
process of elimination figuring out that
stuff in our life
you know that that that stuff that we go
that doesn't feed me
that i've tried that over and over again
it doesn't pay me back well let's get
rid of that let's get rid of those
friends
those places that approach to life and
then
by process elimination we end up with
more of what feeds us
in front of us i love it man
that's amazing so um have you not
watched
many of your films back matthew are you
just when you're done with your
dumbbells
i haven't seen i'm trying to think what
they are i've
i'll i'll usually see this stuff from
the premiere uh
right here and watch it and then never
really watch it again
so
yeah and plus premier viewing's weird
anyway because it's
there's so much expectation on it you've
been a year away you're nervous you're
watching everything so
yeah i've got a i've got a lot of films
to watch again once i love that so
you're
nervous watching some stuff back
when you're seeing it for the first time
plus you're right you know obviously
this is when you're in a room full of
other people seeing it for the first
time
i mean that has got to be i just you
know the self-doubt i i i hear you man
i don't really watch so yeah man i mean
look i've never done a movie or given a
performance
that lived up to my expectations never
where does that come from
i don't know but i can say this
probably the last 10 years that doesn't
cause me angst that actually makes me go
well good did it get close
and if it got close bravo that's as good
as it gets i don't think it
and and then looking at it like oh great
you're never going to have the perfect
game
there's no such thing the amount so
that's and that makes me say oh that's
kind of what life's about
we're all chasing yet we ain't never
going to get there
and that's sort of the point i think um
if i'm never you know that reach exceed
the grasp
always but still be i'm still somewhat
satisfied when i go see work and i go
good job or i like that movie i'll feel
satisfaction
but it's never reached the actual level
of going like wow
that was the one that was perfect
even with one one of the oscar even
dallas buyers club that that's not one
of them
no i mean i mean close awesome but but
different in different aspects uh
better in some ways than i thought was
gonna be but also things that i missed
that my imagination was hoping it was
gonna be from the movie to the
performance and that's one of my
favorite films
just want to pause my conversation with
matthew for a moment to talk about my
sponsors that are making this inaugural
edition of just getting started that
much more special
thrilled to have audible on board man
everybody uses audible if you don't
you need to audible helps you find the
largest selection of audiobooks ranging
from bestsellers and new releases to
celebrity memoirs languages business
motivation
thousands of popular and binge-worthy
podcasts right there on audible
i will tell you this going on long road
trips with your kids
put a book on audible in a car oh my
gosh does it make your life that much
easier my kids
love listening to books on audible if
you got kids
a perfect thing if you want to go on
long road trips want to hear podcasts
want to hear a book
audible makes it perfect and the new
plus catalog makes audible membership so
much more valuable
and gives all members a chance to listen
to and discover new favorites and new
formats
like the exclusive words and music
series or a podcast you've never
considered before
to get started visit audible.com
eisen or text eisen to 500 500 again
to if you will just get started visit
audible.com
eisen or text eisen to 500 500.
another sponsor i want to talk about
right now before we get back to
matthew mcconaughey and what he's up to
here and now
i love my sleep number bed sleep number
is a sponsor let me tell you folks my
sleep number setting is 60. my wife says
70. just 10 numbers apart but it makes
the world of difference because we
can set our side of the bed to exactly
just how soft or firm we want the
mattress
to be one in three american adults
according to the cdc
say they're not getting sufficient sleep
on a regular basis quality sleep can
boost your immune system
and help you become more resistant to
many illnesses what's quality sleep
that's seven to nine hours
a night for adults again it helps you
get a great night's sleep
it helps improve your recovery and
increase energy and also you get to set
your side of the bed to exactly the way
you want it
introducing the new sleep number 360
smart bed designed to make a
life-changing difference
to your health and wellness from 999
only at sleep number stores or sleep
number dot com
slash eisen again at a sleep number
store near you
or sleep number dot com slash eisen so
um well i'll tell you what man um that
i i'm i'm i'm wondering if there's
something in all that
that somebody again who's listening to
this
and hopefully picking this podcast
because of the purpose
for it can hear and and understand that
okay
you're somebody who's been very
successful uh to say the least
um that a big break came from
um an experience that you rolled the
dice on that could have
derailed you a little bit instead it
made you more prepared and confident for
the next one
and even when you do reach success
there's always room for improvement and
there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that none of
that's wrong in some ways
in some ways maybe that's as as good as
it can get
even more so then there's nothing being
wrong with it i mean and not just for me
but i mean for us in in in life we're so
result oriented like
you got to have the ultimate result and
as we started off saying the result's
never really what you think it's going
to be
and so you know we want to reach certain
mountaintop and we feel like when we're
going to get there
whether it's personally relationship
career we feel like oh if i could just
get this
then i'll be happy then i'll be content
then i'll go tada
i did it and we get there and there's no
tata moment
well all of a sudden there's another
mountain there to climb or we've got to
call an audible
or we we got to go there's another trail
and so
it's a little bit of the old hey that's
the journey not the destination if we
can still
check things off on the way of going yep
did that one nice okay did that one
nice good job oh did that one bogeyed on
that one
that failed okay we're still in the game
still in the game stealing the game
and saying we're never gonna we're never
gonna finish what are the best rounds of
golf that anyone ever plays
i know the best rounds of golf i've ever
played is when i'm walking 18
green thinking i'm going to the next tee
box and i have to be reminded that the
round's over
the thing i ever do is when
it's a wrap and i say okay gang to see
you tomorrow and they go no that's a
film wrap everyone's going home
for good i'm like oh really because i
was head down in the process so much
that i didn't know the game was over
best
when when when did teams not choke at
the proverbial finish line
not when they're going oh my gosh 10
seconds we're on the five
what am i going to do no they're still
playing the game
bo jackson didn't cross the goal line
ran through the end zone up the tunnel
let's see it and out
out the door okay i love that yeah
no doubt about that um and you know uh
i'm uh what what what is your your golf
game matthew
right now 26 handicap but i used to be a
four
i was a four in high school check this
out this pisses people off i've had four
holes in one two
the first two hole and ones i had were
11 days
apart
no that piss is some broke off or
something man they're like yeah
i know it i know it yeah i bet so you've
had four
holes in one yeah holy [ __ ] that's
unbelievable
yeah i i i haven't um i haven't come
close
but i do keep trying and it's always
that one shot
at the end at 17 or 18 it just keeps you
coming back
that's everything all you got to do is
hit it pure exactly where you want it
one time you're like because it's so
simple you know
this is a golf's great analogy we're
talking about about things we do in life
calibrate
you know you hadn't played golf you look
down someone comes up goes dude your
stance is like
way wide open like no i'm lined up here
you look down the leg club then i'm like
oh my gosh i'm like a foot open what was
i doing that's why i'm
slicing the ball so you get it straight
you straighten out
you start to hit the ball straight
starts to feel so good
you start to overcompensate a little bit
move that left foot forward next thing
you know you're duck hooking it you
don't know what happened
and same person comes up with look at
your stance you're about
six inches to the right you've got such
a close stance you're snapping
everything like
so we can also overcompensate what
starts going well with us
in our life you know and and it's
consistent balance it seems
well i guess again before we get to the
here and now uh here on the show just
i i mean just thinking of some of your
performances that i thought was pitch
perfect
i mean they're just there there's many
of them um
the wolf of wall street for me is like
every single scene you showed up in
it was dominated and i i'm wondering how
did you approach
that that role well were you dominant
in that one i look for what i call a
launch pad line
in in all my roles i don't always find
them but sometimes they just
are screaming in the headline and neon
letters when i read them
and i go what i mean by launchpad line
is a line i look at i go whoa
who is that i can unpack if that
character i'm playing sees the world
through that lens there's a freaking
5 000 page book on that person meaning
woodson day's confused
he has three lines written one of them
is that's what i love about those high
school girls man i get older but they
stay the same age
well i'm like well if that's that
character's pov
there's a whole book that tells me a lot
about who that guy is about everything
else he does in his life right
well let's get wolf of wall street the
original
scene one of the things that was
scripted when uh the belfor character
leonardo's captain carrick then arnold
dicaprio's character says so what's the
whole this whole game about this this
brokered thing and he goes
cocaine and hookers and i went who is
that i go
there's if that guy doesn't mean that as
a joke if he actually means
cocaine hookers and let me tell you why
i'm like there's a book on that guy that
tells you what he eats what he drinks
where he goes
if he's married what he does at night
and in the morning
and so i started unpacking that guy and
i
said he's a rapper is what he is he's
got a rap here and he is consistently in
the flow so we start to add
things and i go interview all these
different brokers that were around that
time and
and every time when i would say so was
it a racket
and they'd go no
and you'd be like okay okay so i got
the joke underneath this logic
this cocaine and okra logic and then i
just started riffing and writing stuff
and then i and then the original scene
was long but i made it about three times
as long
and what i wrote and then i just showed
up on that day and said i'm gonna
i'm just gonna do it and i did it and
scorsese liked it and leo liked it and
there we go that's it so
now after everything that you've done i
i would imagine that once you've done
something like that
you do look out of the side of your eye
to see if score says he's
happy looking happy
everybody says cut i've only i've been
able to work with the great martin's
crusade once but here's what you know
here's one of the great things i learned
about him
he loves funny
and he sits over the monitor and if you
see him he's those shoulders get going
and his shoulders start bouncing and
that for me was ah
he's digging it um and he loved the
non-verbal stuff he would come up and
do do more of that
yeah he loved that stuff a lot he's very
musical
well i mean you could even say too you
know obviously the famous goodfellas
scene
with pesci where he's saying um what am
i how am i funny am i clowned
that is funny that is there is some sort
of funny
aspect of the terror that's happening
dangerously funny
yes yes you know i love that that you
see he's
he loves funny the mountain
bloody funny you know that's right and
then
soderbergh uh magic mike what was the
what was the
the line for you there where if you
could recall from that
character so stephen soderbergh calls me
pitches the thing and
when she played this guy he was sort of
the next trip he's probably still
dancing but he runs the club now you
know and i'm like okay and he goes
i can get a script to you in a couple of
weeks and i went wait a minute stephen
first time i'm talking about i said look
i my you got to give me something i for
two weeks i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be all over the place give me
some line that i can take from here
that can give me just a a launch a
diving board which i can take with me
i when we hang up and he was quiet for a
second
and also he goes and the character's
name is dallas he goes well
you know dallas he's pretty connected to
the ufos
man
that's what he says that's what he said
so i said
oh well take the roof off of wherever
your imagination's going for this
character because this guy
is lunar here we go and so i just
started saying he's his capitalist he's
doing this he's doing that and made him
you know what what how made him as corny
as i could go
um as well as being a bit dangerous but
that line is what he gave me which
is what a great piece of direction from
anybody because basically it's saying
you're free sir yes further
no that's not far you want to go further
go as far as you'd like sir
no i wasn't getting nervous about how
high you were keep going if you want
man i love that uh matthew mcconaughey
here on just getting started
so let's talk about the here and now uh
austin fc
let's talk about being the owner of a
football club as they would call it
certainly across the pond as they do
also here now in america you are the ceo
of austin fc as of uh 2019 right that's
when you first
one that one of the co-owners of it uh
yes okay as uh
years ago and we're gonna have our first
ball on the pitch here i believe in
well just in a few months
what is that experience like for you
been so far as you're getting set to
very very
very fun and cool i mean it's it's
things are coming together a lot of
great things are coming together here
number one
i travel the world what's the one game
that's played everywhere
that's it soccer ball greatest
invitations in the world
we're in rome you're in iceland you're
in cleveland you're in new york you're
in
johannesburg you're sitting around at
the table having lunch
somebody's got a ball down the street
kids you anyone can just walk up you
don't have to introduce yourself just
walk up
open up a foot ball comes to you kick it
around it happens you can pick up a game
anywhere in the world
my kids play it my wife is brazilian so
i'm getting to know
that soccer's in their blood um
reintroduced me
to the love of soccer i've always loved
the world cup but now i'm really
starting to follow soccer
now mls soccer's coming to america and
it's real now it's established here the
things are strong um soccer's on the com
got the world cup coming in 26. we're
gonna be hosting on our front porch
the world's game yes austin texas
young town one of the fastest growing
cities in the nation
becoming a metropolis progressive
looking forward
never had a pro team never had a team
that we could root for our city
oh it's high time for it so these things
coming together the city of austin
my personal knowledge and love of the
game that's growing through my family
and travels
and the fact that the game of soccer
is growing so well in the united states
now what our fun chance is really which
is why this is so much fun for me
is how yes soccer's coming to austin but
now how do we take austin to soccer
how does our game experience the 21 000
on any given night at q2
stadium unlike any other and
we're i'm thinking very fun i mean it's
obvious can be a family affair but it
should be a highly rowdy affair
that yes represent now we have a place
there's a great diversity in austin
well now we have one place where
everyone can go on any given night
in austin all the little boroughs of
austin have a place to convene now
in that stadium over a game that is the
world's game
and so um have you
is there a part of this that you didn't
expect that you learned something
again i'm kind of trying to weave uh the
the main theme of this pod
into you taking on something new
um and and figuring out what to
what to make of it well let me define
that so i'm
i'm trying to measure my choices now
that i
gonna invest my time in
i ask myself well matthew is this a
legacy choice meaning is this a choice
that
in 10 years you can look back and go oh
i'm still glad that's on my
desk is this a choice that when you're
on your deathbed you can look back and
go oh yeah
i enjoyed building that is this a choice
that hopefully you can hand off to
your kids or other people that can keep
it alive after you're gone
soccer the game of football in in austin
is something that checks all those boxes
for me um i love hard work but i also
want to have things that i look forward
to having on my proverbial monday
morning desk
and this is one of those it's in my
backyard
it's where i live my kids love the game
we'd want to go anyway whether i was an
owner or not
well let's get in there i know austin
very well i feel like i got a pulse on
the culture and the dna
here oh yeah um
and so it's it's it's been fun work
so far you know and the owners our
ownership group is is
i think we're doing a good job so far
our first impression before we've even
put a ball on the pitch we've got
record-breaking jersey sales so the the
appetite's there the beavers there as
well
and when i i want to build a team that's
legacy we have
cultural giants in austin texas well now
let's go create some
new cultural giants on the pitch and
build something where it's a hundred
year war
man where where my kids are taking over
for me that we're looking back in 60
years going yeah look what we built
and we were austin from day one and
we're growing as
austin whatever day that is in the
future hopefully for
hundreds of years you're gonna deal with
talent relations you're gonna be able to
deal with these players have them
come come to your desk stare them down
what do what
wants to meet with the players at my
desk i'll meet
players out there on the pitch all right
and go over there
and go yeah i know i can't play this
game but i'd rather meet you out here
and
and look yeah it's a it's a i'll
probably enjoy that in a similar way
and i'll be curious to see how it's
different that i enjoy talking to
players for the university of texas
longhorns
that i enjoy talking to these young men
who are 18 to 22 years old
right we'll be talking to men that are
that age and a little bit older but are
in a professional sport
of soccer so and and you know and it's
going to be different languages we got
south american players it's gonna
the colors and i'll find out from from
them
you know i mean what are the different
i'm going to keep learning what are the
different cultures that soccer brings
from their countries
and do we have that established in our
city because i'll bet you that the
diversity that
so far the diversity we have in the
players and the team has a mirror of the
diversity in the city as well like it
does
we have those communities that are from
places that our players are from as well
in our city i think steve tish the owner
of the giants
is the only owner in professional north
american sports to have an oscar
and a championship trophy because he won
he was the director he was the producer
of forrest gump
okay so he's so that you have you can
join
a very very small class of people
matthew here to have to have
your hands full you know of some of some
trophies
maybe we want inside the arm as well
that'd be good that's true yes
i shouldn't just use the hands i should
use the entire the entire
you know body i like the way you think
that's what you got to think as an owner
you got to be greedy
you got to be greedy in sports well we
want to win that's for sure
at the same time you know can we sit
there and and
expect to have an absolutely outstanding
product day one i don't know we got
claudio rania and coach josh wolfe
putting together
the team they're very happy with the
team they handle that over there i'm on
the outskirts of that learning from
claudio
you know about what players and why and
what kind of team
ages where they're from how to start a
team it's it's
stuff i've wanted to do all my life
but now i'm getting to do it instead of
just show up and be a fan
have some skin in the game and then uh
um
also on the here and now this book um a
million
copies sold um of green lights
what and again that that kind of
dovetails into the
main theme of this pod matthew
uh the reaction that you have received
from this book did it meet uh we talked
about meeting expectations in terms of
your acting
did it meet your expectations in terms
of authoring
matthew well i i got to be honest i
didn't really have
expectations because i had no
measurement i had no context i'd never
written a book before it was a new
arena i could i could you know i could
analyze and go it's kind of like putting
a movie out and it doesn't do well
um but it was different and
a goal early on was number one new york
times best seller
boom it happened not just best seller
list date on the number one of the new
york time bestsellers
now it's still there 18 19 weeks later
i'm still enjoying talking about it i'm
doing a remote circuit i've talked
my favorite thing is i talked about
similar subjects
20 30 times with 20 30 different people
over and over and over for the last 18
weeks
but every single conversation is
specific and different even though it
may be about the same subject
so what i'm seeing is people are going
hey i read your story
of your life but i it reminded me of
my own life is what they're telling me
and it reminded me of this time in my
life or this choice i want to make
and so they're able to internalize it
make it subjective to them and tell me
hey
this is really helpful and it's fun
and and it's helping me with success
it's helping me with failure so
that it's becoming uh um that it's
spreading like that and translating
like that to so many people um
i guess i could say maybe i hoped for it
but didn't know
that it would it would it would happen
to this amount i was hoping that i had
something to share
that people that humanity could go yes
yes
i see myself in that too matthew and but
to this extent so far i
i don't think i i had a i could have
measured this
so i guess what would be in closing here
um
the one piece of advice that you would
give to somebody about making choices
that they have a choice right now
to make about anything yeah but most
importantly
you know maybe it is a career choice
maybe it is a
a choice that they have to make in order
to reach a goal
family-wise or what yeah is there
anything that you you'd have
on that front yeah i could go i got a
few
i mean i'm gonna lean into something i
alluded to earlier which is
we don't do this enough and i think it's
a really important thing to try and do
when we're faced with the decision to
make just project
into the future a little bit maybe
that's just tomorrow
maybe that's next week maybe six months
maybe it's 10 years from now maybe it's
on your deathbed
just project out there and look back and
go
am i going to enjoy the view looking
back at this decision i made
am i going to go i don't know if i'm
going to get it or not i don't know if
it'll be a success or failure
but am i going to look back and go yeah
all right i
i appreciated that choice of where you
were at that time in your life
it's just a little trick to do with
ourselves but it's very very
useful it helps us become objective
about our subjective personal decision
that we're making
and a lot of times when we're making
these big decisions we feel like we're
the center of the world and
the world's revolving around us and this
decision is so important sometimes we
give it too much import as i said
earlier sometimes she's like damn it
make a decision and commit
but we feel like the world's revolving
around about us if we project
into the future and look back at
ourselves in that decision that's
getting objective
it's kind of like popping back well
how's that decision i'm gonna make how's
it gonna play out
what are the different scenarios how
that could play out it can be very
helpful
in making the decision um also i'll just
say
making tough decisions are uncomfortable
there's good discomfort and there's bad
discomfort ask yourself why you're
afraid of each decision
if i'm if i'm afraid of a decision
because i'm like i don't know what's
going to happen it's just the unknown
but i'm so excited
maybe that's a good fear to have maybe
that's a reason to lean into it now if
i'm afraid to make a decision because
i'm like i don't
trust the pedigree i don't think that
the people i'd be working with have the
best interest to me
well that's a bad kind of fear you
should listen to that and maybe not do
it
bet on yourself it's got to be personal
doesn't mean you're going to get it
every time but if you bet on yourself
and you don't half-ass it
if it works you can look in the mirror
and go yes
and if it doesn't work you can look in
the mirror and go
guilty but no is a hell of a lot better
than laying down at night going i'm just
not sure
what would have happened if i woulda
love it love all of it you're the best
man um
i i i can't leave this podcast and go
see my children
without ask telling them what a buster
moon told me about
sing too and when it's coming because
they know i'm talking to buster moon
today
that's the character you played in sing
which my children have seen
a million times and it's a dynamite film
what what does a scoop would
sing too sing too right now we're set
for
for christmas at the end of this year
fantastic
and and garth director's extremely
excited about it chris maladantri is
very
well donji's very excited about it with
illumination i haven't seen it yet i'm
looking forward to seeing it too
um but those things are so much fun to
work
work on to play on because they're not
work they're fun to play on
and um you know i'd never done i started
doing the animated films because
people kept asking my kids what their
favorite films of their dads was
and i'm like i don't make many films my
kids can see
you mean they haven't they haven't seen
true detective yet
it's not maybe tomorrow you know not yet
no that's going to open up a lot of
questions i'm not ready to answer
sing two is more their speed and more of
their lane
how old are they how old are you got uh
12
uh 11 and 8. well they've got some
viewing to do once upon uh
in the future but for the moment buster
moon will suffice that's fantastic
you're the best thanks again matthew uh
i really greatly appreciate you helping
kick start my new podcast just getting
started
green lights is available where all
books are sold go get that austin fc
jersey i look forward to seeing that
ball out on the pitch i look forward to
seeing you in the owner's suite or
are you going to be like uh again i know
you're a washington football guy or
you're going to be like jerry jones on
the on the
on the pitch right at the end are you
gonna be one of those guys
i'll have to see it's hard to keep me
off the grass okay
i love it you take care of yourself
matthew thanks for the thank you for
doing this
that's matthew mcconaughey right here on
just getting started
well that's episode one matthew
mcconaughey is just a fantastic
fantastic storyteller and um and i'm
thrilled that
i was able to get him for the first pod
of just getting started and bring it on
to you and so
you know everyone is up to speed um the
way that this is gonna work is i'll chat
with somebody i'll start with
their origin story get to the here and
now and then maybe
uh finish up with a story of my own to
uh to leave you with and also
that gets inspired by something i've
just heard from the guest
and matthew mcconaughey telling that
story
about having an absolute
cold sweat that just broke out on the
back of his neck
when he thought you know what i'll just
wing it i'll just wing it
for a scene because he wanted to make
sure that how tight he was
uh wouldn't be brought into this job
because he was so tight in
job after job after job or audition
after audition so he's going to
take it a totally different approach be
loose
and that's the time when he gets a four
page side
in spanish and that reminded me of my
first ever
sports center and it was 1996
i was 26 years old and i had just gotten
the job
on sportscenter on espn
um by sending a tape of my work
that i had uh been conducting at a small
television market kr crtv
in redding california the abc affiliate
of uh of the reading chico market little
did i know at the time that a young man
in
chico california um named aaron rodgers
was out there in the audience he and i
have never had a conversation about that
but he grew up in
in chico california just when i was a
sports anchor
so the probability was there but i
didn't agree it was a small market
and i sent a tape to a headhunter under
the category of you never know
you just never know who's going to see
it so i sent and it all was going to do
is cost me first class postage
so i take the tape put it in an envelope
put first class postage on it send it to
a headhunter never know
well sure enough and i might tell the
story in greater detail
or pull out the greater detail later on
in future podcasts but
long story short is i did get a call
from one of the headhunters and that did
lead
to my job at sportscenter my dream job
at espn at age
26. and
my first sports center was in the middle
of march
of 1996. it was a saturday
seven o'clock eastern sports center
which they don't have that time slot
anymore but at any rate
it was right there early evening on a
saturday
during march madness i think it was the
first weekend i think
had to have been the round of 32 of the
1996 march madness
uh tournament and larry beale was the
other anchor and i remember
being nervous very very nervous and i
tried to stay loose just like matthew
try to stay loose
need to stay loose um and i tried to
prepare for it
but the problem was is the games that i
would be doing the highlights of
on this show were all happening they
were all happening
it was all going down i mean it's march
madness you know that you know
games are non-stop they're tipping off
like every 15 minutes it feels like
and it feels like whenever you're
watching it that's what makes it so
great
and i remember thinking to myself how am
i going to prepare for this
how can i stay loose what am i going to
do
and um it was time to
go down to the studio for my first ever
sports center and i had about 12 games
of highlights in the show
and add only the paperwork they give you
a shot sheet to read off of
in in notes form knowing what shots are
going to appear on the screen so you
knew the information of who had the ball
and what the score was and
how much time is left on the clock and
what have and so on and so forth
so i had the paperwork and it only
seemed the highlight
of one of the 12 that i had in the show
in other words i would have to ad-lib
11 of the 12 highlights i had in the
show
sight unseen like normally you would get
this
highlight you'd look at it you'd watch
it you'd go over it so you know what you
might say when you say it on the air on
live tv
and i remember thinking to myself
walking down to the set i had two
choices
that's it i boiled it down to two
choices try to make it very easy
for me to remain calm and i remember
thinking to myself i had two choices
one was to suck it up
and know that this was my dream moment
and i had been betting on myself my
entire life
that i was waiting for this moment and
it finally arrived albeit not what the
attention to detail that would have
calmed my nerves
or the preparation that i wanted or ever
envisioned
i would not have going down
to the studio that was choice a
choice b was to pee down my leg and i
thought to myself you know that's not a
choice
it's uh definitely not a choice let's
choose choice a
and uh i don't know how the show went i
think it went well i mean
you know i wasn't fired on the spot um i
was bouncing off the walls
but i just remember thinking to myself i
got two choices
one is to go with the flow go at the
moment
believe in yourself know that this
moment that you've been waiting for your
entire life has arrived and
meet it meet the moment and the other
choice is to panic
which might feel good at the time but
never would work out in a million years
and i know that may sound over
simplified and many of the pieces of
advice or stories you hear may sound
well that's really simple i didn't
i knew that already sometimes what you
know you need to hear
um and that's that that is uh
um an absolute belief that i have
that sometimes you think you know but
you still need to hear it
for you to believe it
that's it for this first episode of just
getting started next week's
guest is damon john of shark tank we'll
see you next week on just getting
started right here on westwood one